jo große Ereignisse werfen ihre Schatten
voraus dieses Jahr im Sommer große
Kinopremiere von Cars 2 dem neuen
Animationsfilm aus dem Hause Pixar da
würd hier auf dem Kanal eine Menge noch
zu hören und zu sehen geben und heute
aber erstmal eine sehr
finde ich faszinierende News und zwar
eine der Sprecherinnen bei diesem Film
einer der deutschen Sprecherin wird
niemand anderes sein als cold mirror sie
hat eine kleine Sprechrolle bekommen
also das schon mal spannend und heute
ein ganz besonderes Ereignis der Cars 2
Deutsche spezialtrailer exklusiv bei uns
auf Youtube gibt's die
trailerpremiere gleich um 17 Uhr das
heißt hier wird's ab 17 Uhr heute ein
Link im Video geben da könnt ihr drauf
gehen es ist auf unserem Kanal und dann
könnt ihr diesen speziell für
Deutschland geschnitten Trailer sehen
den es auf Youtube nur bei uns gibt viel
Spaß